معجزه في كولومبيا اربعه اطفال تاهو في
الادغال لمده اربعين يوما وعثر عليهم من
قبل رجال انقاذ الحمد لله احياء الاطفال
فقدوا او فقدوا في غابه الامازون بعد
نجاتهم من تحطم طائره صغيره كانت تقول لهم
واسفرت عن مقتل والدتهم والطيار واحد
اقربائهم تضاءل طبعا فر ص مقار
على قعبه حاضنه للحيوانات المفترسه خاصه
ان اكبرهم لزلي تبلغ من العمر 13 عاما فقط
لكن شقيق الكبرى وصفت بالبطله بعدما نجت
في رعايه اشقائها بما فيهم الرضيع التي
تبلغ عاما واحدا طبعا لنتذكر قصص مماثله
كثيره ربما تابعناها في السنوات الاخيره
مشاهدينا لميس ستذكرنا بهذه القصص تفضلي
يا لميس
[موسيقى]
طال من ادغال كولومبيا ملهمه بالتاكيد
وشبيهه لعمليه انقاذ
شهدت اهتماما عالميا كبيرا وقتها القصه
الاشهر من تايلند وتحديدا في يونيو عام
2018 حين تم انقاذ فريق لكره القدم 12
طفلا ومدربهم بعد معالقوا بداخل كهف
غمرتهم ياها الفيضانات ل 17 يوما وفي 2010
امضى 33 رجلا من عمال المناجم في تشيلي
اكثر من شهرين تحت الارض بعد انهيار من
جونسون للتنقيب عن النحاس والذهب واستغرق
انتشار جميع العمال حوالي 22 ساعه اخيرا
عام
1987 سقطت بيبي جاسيكا رضيعه بالغه من
العمر 18 شهرا في بئر بالحديقه الخلفيه
لمنزل خالتها في تكساس وحرره عمال انقاذ
بعد يومين ونصف عمليه الانقاذ هذه اذيعت
وقتها على الهواء مباشره
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات